trois petites notes de musique on
priez-vous
creux du
souvenirs sans l'infini dans sa page
elle tourne la page et vont s'endormir
mais un jour sans crier
elle vous reviennent dans mes mois
toi
tu voulais oublier
un petit air galvaudé
tu n'oublieras jamais
et la rue elle était
une fille qui followers
je vous aime chanter la rengaine
sublimes pourvu que la rime amène
toujours
une romance de vacances
qui lancinante ou relance vrai
elle était si jolie
petit frère j'ai pas nouilles
et tu l'as pas cueilli
pour son premier frisson
elle t'offre une chanson
apprendre les
le temps et le danse l'espace d'un
refrain
à la la la
la la la la
3 petites musiques qui bouffent la vie
que du fond des souvenirs